chronique environnement comme chaque
mardi au cours du 7 8 aux alentours de
18h30 nous allons parler de l'animalerie
c'est une formation ça s'apprend c'est
une vraie filière il ya un lycée qui
apprend justement ce métier dans les
yvelines
oui l'unique formation sanctionnée par
un diplôme en ile de france se trouve à
moules c'est le lycée
l'udc va laisser à chacun le sait j'ai
déjà pour un chrono commence tout juste
ça veut dire d'aller vous ce soir pour
en parler avec nous stéphane ouest
bonsoir et eric gross au conte soir à
tous les deux donc vous êtes vous
stéphanois est responsable animalier et
formateur en aux techniques et eric
gross où vous êtes professeur de
biologie et développement durable
alors le lycée agricole est ouvert
depuis 1951
aujourd'hui plus de 400 élèves venus de
toute la france y étudient en demi
pension ou en pension complète
la filière animalerie elle a été créée
en 2005 avec tout d'abord des animaux de
compagnie classique mais les goûts
évoluent nous le verrons d'ailleurs au
liffré nous nous sommes rendus donc sur
place au lycée agricole le bus a avec
elodie moines pour rencontrer ses futurs
spécialistes des animaux
la passion des animaux jusque pendant
les heures de pause au lycée agricole le
béa
les élèves du club nature créée il ya
deux ans prennent soin des tourterelles
rougequeue noir et pivert qui peuplent
le parc l'hiver ce lycée d'enseignement
privé est le seul possédant une filière
animalerie dans toute l'ile-de-france
sanctionnée par un diplôme reconnu
alors cette filière on apprend les bases
des animaux de compagnie c'est à dire on
apprend à peu près l'équivalent de 300
espèces animales rongeurs aquariophilie
oiseaux mais aussi reptiles sont au
programme
car les nac nouveaux animaux de
compagnie sont de plus en plus prisé à
l'embêter un petit peu parce que c'est
une espèce que j'ai bien dormi
donc la rapid on roule
le python bull
un serpent qui peut atteindre un mètre
cinquante et tue ses proies par
constriction le spécimen n'effraie pas
les élèves les goûts pour les animaux
ont largement évolué dérangeant pour
simhat ans et plus les régimes ce que je
suis passé le toucher est ce que c'est
une nouveauté quand les élèves qui
viennent de partout en france n'ont
qu'une seule motivation jeu 6/3 tout
simplement par passion
donc voilà reptiles et poissons coup ici
une centaine d'élèves est réparti entre
les classes de seconde de première et de
terminale
d'autres choisissent l'apprentissage ou
le bts technico-commercial 70 à 80 % des
élèves se destinent qu'à la vente en
animalerie
d'autres se dirigent vers un métier de
l'assistanat au vétérinaire ou encore
vers l'élevage l'animalerie reste l'un
des secteurs qui recrutent encore
aujourd'hui et si le respect des animaux
fait partie intégrante de l'enseignement
du lycée le respect de l'environnement
aussi le lycée agricole qui s'agrandit
actuellement a été distingué par un
écolabel ça veut dire que tous les
animaux qu'on avait dans ce reportage
les gens sont amenés un jour
éventuellement les avoir supprimées
fritz ou des serpents hésité par une
formidable et ça me rassure pas voilà
donc il ya plusieurs formations stéphane
ouest qui se décline un bts en
apprentissage comment ça se passe nous
avons deux formations différentes une
formation bac professionnel technicien
conseil vente en animalerie
quand accessible à partir de la
troisième ou premières secondes
et là on a une formation au niveau du
lycée donc une formation
scolaires comme les jeunes connaissent
avec le relais les vacances c'est tout
et une formation par apprentissage
du coup on a vu dans le reportage c'est
une filière qui ne connaît pas la crise
vers quel métier s'oriente ces jeunes
alors c'est une filière qui est en plein
boom oui parce que avant on parlait de
30 millions d'amis maintenant on en est
à 61 millions et quelques en france un
d'amis donc voilà le marché a énormément
évolué a doublé depuis un peu près vingt
ans les jeunes finissants ce cycle
scolaire s'oriente principalement vers
le métier de animalier pour devenir
responsable animalier où est responsable
de secteur ou là ils vont être amenés à
gérer des animaux d entre eux devaient
s'entretenir et l ai donné une idée
vendre aussi et une autre partie de nos
élèves serions aussi pour vers le métier
d'auxiliaire vétérinaire ou assistante
vétérinaire et d'autres s'y sont vont
plutôt destiné à être vers l'élevage
c'est bien mais principalement l'élevage
des reptiles l'élevage des perroquets
car il ya des filières qui sont déjà
spécialisées dans l'élevage de chiens
chats par exemple à nous c'est plutôt
dans le animaux très exotique il y en a
aussi qui s'oriente dans le métier de
soigneur au sein de voir des jeunes
venus s'orienter aussi vers le souvenir
de
le métier de soigneur animalier qui l'a
qui concerne les eaux mais qui reste
quand même un petit peu à bouger mais
qui reste ce ne sont pas des
vétérinaires
non non ce faux pas des vétérans
différence non c'est vraiment au niveau
du bac et bts ses technico commercial là
c'est plutôt c'est un diplôme récente
depuis 2010 technique que commerciale
option animaux d'élevage et de compagnie
ou là ils sont destinés à travailler
plutôt d'un des firmes comme royal canin
purina l'isi santé en plusieurs donc on
attend des sociétés des fournisseurs en
animalerie d'accord donc il y à 300
espèces qui sont étudiés tout au long de
cette formation
alors bien sûr les 300 espèces ne sont
pas représentés au sein de l'école non
non non non nous faudra une très grande
année on a vu qu'il y avait pas de
chiens et de chats
pourquoi c'est une question d'entretien
disons que les chiens les chats les mets
que les jeux les jeunes en magasins vont
les manipuler assez régulièrement et
en laissant plutôt demandeurs de
d'éléments plus complexes comme
l'aquariophilie par exemple qui est
quelque chose qui paraît compliqué dont
elle a besoin de beaucoup de manipuler
autrement il ya aussi les reptiles est
aussi une question de place une question
de c'est plus facile d'installer mme
chirac alors chiens et chats demeure
pour autant même si les goûts évoluent
les les animaux préférés des français
des foyers mais aujourd'hui voilà on
peut on veut posséder chez soi un
perroquet un serpent oui plus en plus
sur les chiens les chats et drôle d'idée
mais j'aime beaucoup évolué dans les
chiens et les chats c'est le nombre de
possesseurs maintenant être à dix
millions de chats et de chiens les chats
et a dépassé même le chien dont fait
partie des pays avant le plus de chiens
chats donc c'est un très gros marché
c'est le gros marché au niveau de
l'animalerie sur l'alimentation
par contre le marché s'est diversifié
aussi par rapport aussi l'offre et la
demande
c'est à dire au niveau des oiseaux ce
qui est à la mode c'est non seulement
plus tôt les perroquets mais aussi les
oiseaux tout ce qui est élevé à la main
c'est à dire des oiseaux qu'on ne va pas
spécialement pas spécialement destiné à
être en cage en permanence mais aussi à
avoir un contact avec l'humain un vrai
contact entre l'aquariophilie évolue
aussi plutôt dans les petits aquariums
décoratifs aussi technique mais c'est
bon là c'est un petit peu fini les
grands hommes
et puis après les reptiles qui sont en
plein boom depuis deux trois ans les
éleveurs aussi bien les saveurs ce que
les magasins donc les magasin truffaut
toutes les jardineries animalerie ouvre
maintenant des sections reptiles qui est
votre animal de compagnie est-ce que
vous en avez un animal de compagnie oui
non j'en ai pas chez moi j'ai tout donné
tout ceux du lycée c'est un bouc
émissaire
moi je suis dépôts sont chaque fois sont
d'accord valérie ont fait un tour de
table
ça c'est sûr je n'ai pas de serpents et
c'est pas demain la veille à quelqu'un
qui les fera animal de compagnie c'est
la question que nous sommes allez vous
poser aujourd'hui dans les rues de 50
ans et mais non non non pas du tout pas
cher pendant pourquoi parce que j'ai
peur de tout ces petits noms annonce
surtout j horror
non les animaux de compagnie chiens ça
sera plutôt un chien animal exotique pas
du tout c'est pas trop en délire c'est
juste que en plus ma femme sera pas trop
content kiev est un rongeur mais non
sinon tout ce qui est un secteur et
petit que ça j'aime pas trop pas du tout
non d'une part parce que ce sont des
animaux qui d'une part de ma femme
n'aime pas à renier moi j'aime pas trop
le serpent le choix serait assez rapide
le nombre d animaux de compagnie ce
serait plutôt rachat
j'ai eu avec quoi serpents des
couleuvres mais cette confidence de
valérie français micro trottoir elle
préfère dormir chez elle avec un chat
dans son livre plutôt qu'avec un ce à
quoi alors on voit qu'il ya justement
les nac qui sont apparus ces nouveaux
animaux de compagnie il n'y a pas de
limite
est ce qu'il y à des animaux qu'on ne
peut pas posséder chez soi a bien sûr
niveau la législation en france est très
stricte
au niveau des reptiles principalement
mais aussi des animaux compagnie bon ben
il est interdit de vendre un de ces
animaux sans avoir un certificat de
capacité pour les espèces domestiques ou
non domestiques les serpents font partie
des espèces non domestiques
il ya eu un arrêté en 2006 qui interdit
par exemple tout serpent qui dépasse 3 m
donc à partir de trois mètres il faut
être capable chez elle à partir de trois
mètres c'est un cadre juridique
spécifique
les tortues c'est au niveau de la
mâchoire elle doit faire plus de 4 cm
donc tout ce qui est considéré comme
espèces dangereuses tiendra aussi pour
les deux gars c'est vrai alors les
mygales sont devenus totalement
interdite les scorpions les venimeux
c'est à dire la fouettent capacitaire de
possession avoir un diplôme délivré par
les seniors raciale mais rapport à nos
voisins aussi j'imagine législation
particulière les chiens dits dangereux
les chiens de première et deuxième
catégorie à leur première catégorie
normalement on ne devrait plus en avoir
ce qui est petit bout les compagnies
donc doivent être stérilisés il faut un
permis et août et les chiens de deuxième
catégorie où il ya un cadre très précis
surtout qu'on les amène dans public
c'est à dire mieux avec une muselière
donc les pieds il ya des empereurs des
amendes très lourdes ou des sanctions
pénales si on respecte bien serré avec
tout ça on apprend bien sûr il ya une
heure de cadre juridique par semaine
vous parliez tout à l'heure notamment
des oiseaux
on l'a vu dans le sujet il y à un club
nature que qui est à votre initiative
eric grosso qu'est ce que c'est que ce
club nature le club nature c'est un club
qui permit aux élèves sur leurs
activités extrascolaires 2
découvrir les animaux qui sont dans le
parc du lycée puisqu'on a la chance
d'avoir un parent qui fait à peu près 2
hectares autour d'établissements
donc c'est dans ce club nature il
découvre les oiseaux les puis surtout
les oiseaux en fait d'accord le lycée
agricole est particulièrement engagée
vers l'environnement
on avait vu lors de notre visite avec
elodie moines et des panneaux des
panneaux solaires mais aussi du compost
c'est vous qui gérez tout ça c'est vous
qui est assez cette initiative notamment
le lycée a été soulignée d'un écolabel
donc qu'ils allaient effectivement là
d'une démarche éco label qui nous permet
de développer un tas de d'activité en
termes de développement durable les
panneaux solaires le compost c'est moi
qu'ils coordonnent au niveau
d'établissement mais ça permet à tous
les enseignants et même aux personnels
non enseignants de se mobiliser dans ce
projet là donc c'est un projet qui est
plutôt fédérateur d'un établissement qui
permet voilà tout le monde d'y
participer
vous avez aussi des moutons à partir de
mars donc on a les moutons qui viennent
au mois de mars qui restent en général
jusqu'à l'été qui reviennent aux prêts à
l'automne encore deux mois
il contribue à l'entretien des parties
herbeuse du parc donc on a des prés où
ils et pâtures et c'est à la fois donc
un intérêt écologique par rapport à
l'entretien du parc mais c'est aussi un
support pour les cours pour les élèves
de 4e sur le thème animal puisqu'ils ont
des cours pour les sensibiliser à la
proche de l'animal comment se comporter
avec des animaux et donc les moutons
sont bien adaptés en termes de taille de
docilité vous élève de 4e 3e
vous êtes professeur de biologie de
développement durable est ce que
justement lors de vos cours vous parler
de ces questions d'environnement et de
respect de l'environnement vos élèves
oui c'est aborder dans les cours où on
peut
travailler cette thématique là c'est pas
forcément toujours le prof de biologie
l'écologie qui fait du développement
durable ça permet aussi de faire
travailler les autres profs dans des
matières comme l'histoire h et où même
les profs de commerce entre les
questions de commerce équitable donc
cédé le développement durable c'est
quelque chose qui se veut fédérateur
d'un établissement et qui permet de voir
mobiliser tout le monde sur une
thématique pendant une année
alors justement la thématique de
l'écolabel en 2012 était la solidarité
vous avez également une filière de
services à la personne qui rencontre
aussi beaucoup de succès donc on a les
deux filières services à la personne
avec un bac pro services à la personne
et aux territoires est une filière aussi
c'est ap pour ce les élèves qui sortent
de troisième je rappelle aussi que le
lycée est partenaire depuis novembre
2012 du secours populaire des yvelines
donc notamment par le biais de ce
service à la personne entre autres oui
c'est les élèves du service à la
personne qui se mobilise souvent le plus
facilement dans les activités de
solidarité mais c'est aussi ouvert aux
élèves de la filière animaleries et on a
différentes activités qui sont proposées
sur la solidarité il ya un club
manille terre avoue son établissement
qui permet de mobiliser les élèves sur
des actions ponctuelles en faveur d'une
association et également
un club unicef qui permet aussi de
mobiliser des ailes à noter que le fort
de son succès la filière animalerie donc
ça gronde y puisque actuellement il y à
un nouvel internat qui sera ouvert
normalement à 100 à la rentrée à 240
élèves supplémentaires
fecteau dernière question tous les
élèves qui vont venir justement dans
cette formation sont quasiment assurés
de trouver à une profession à l'emploi
derrière ça va très vite on ne fait pas
encore d'études menez les célèbres nous
ai plein le régulièrement pour nous
faire part de ce qu'ils font en a
beaucoup qui travaillent dans ceux qui
cherchent vraiment du métier trouvent
dans cette voie ce qu'on ait encore un
magasin qui m'appelait ya deux ou trois
jours pour trois 3 postes à pourvoir
donc c'est encore des magasins qui
s'agrandissent et qui s'ils se développe
énormément dans cette période difficile
pour trouver un emploi et les chiffres
du chômage qui explose on en parle
suffisamment régulièrement pour aussi
souligné lorsque les choses vont plutôt
bien bien samed avoir parlé de votre
formation merci à vous deux allez on va
poursuivre avec à la jambe a à présent
de l'environnement oui et puis on reste
au lycée le buat puisque la première
rencontre départementale des
ambassadeurs de l'unicef se tiendra au
lycée l'ubu à samedi 19 janvier à partir
de 14 heures le choix de ce lycée
s'imposait de lui-même puisque 16 jeune
ambassadrice de l'unicef sont parmi les
élèves
et puis pour apprendre à jardiner est
également au rendez vous oui les
jardiniers de france organise une
conférence avec débat sur le thème
légumes d'autrefois et légumes
d'aujourd'hui samedi 12 janvier à 14h à
mutine et enfin voisins le bretonneux
pardon c'est presque fini à l'esprit on
y va ce sera au centre alfred de vigny
merci à mardi prochain
reposez vous bien prochaine chronique de
l'environnement au même horaire fort
très de l'ue dalila à présent c'est une
couturière d'intérieur tapissière elle
s'est occupée des rideaux et des
tapisseries au château de breteuil vous
avez sans doute déjà vu ses réalisations
regarder
tous
dalila et couturières et auto
entrepreneuse depuis un an et demi elle
est installée en france il y a neuf ans
si dans son pays d'origine au portugal
elle était chef d'une entreprise de
linge de maison ici
dalila a dû tout reconstruire j'ai
commencé à être très attiré par la
petite piste serait aussi que je faisais
déjà avant mais en france il a trouvé le
problème de tous les styles qui sont
différents de mon petit pays et donc
j'ai forgé suivi une formation avec un
tapissier que ce soit la partie rurale
comme pour les fauteuils dalila a mis en
pratique son savoir faire au château de
breteuil
elle s'est occupée des tapisseries des
rideaux ou encore d'une robe créée
spécialement pour une exposition de
l'arop adams a été un défi
si j'ai accepté au château ça m'a fait
très plaisir de la faire j'aime beaucoup
tout ce qui est ce genre de robe
d'europe comme ça de même les robes
marié tout ça j'aime beaucoup tout ça
dalila aime relever le challenge
les défis stimule sa créativité exemple
avec cette petite botte de couture que
personne n'a encore réussi à restaurer
mais après donc le ciseau va rentrer ici
toutes les petites pièces vont trouver
sa place aujourd'hui dalila travail pour
des antiquaires parisiens et des
particuliers et cherche à étendre son
réseau
je fais tout ce qui à linge de maison
pour commencer donc des les rideaux les
embrasse les voilà je les couvre lit les
nappes chemin de table tous les
serviettes tout ce qui à linge de maison
et après donc j'ai fait aussi la
tapisserie soit la tapisserie murale que
j'aime beaucoup faire aussi et sinon les
fauteuils les chaises la can à pied
l'état morel tous ces gens de là que ça
soit d'époque ou moderne comporte
pour la restauration complète de ce
fauteuil il a fallu deux jours de
travail à dalila pour refaire les
sangles replacer les ressorts remettre
le crin et enfin coudre un nouveau tissu
et poser des clous les prix varient en
fonction de l'état du fauteuil allant de
250 à 800 euros
lorsqu'un projet arrive à sa fin et
dalila récupère les chutes de tissus
elle confectionne avec de petits
poussins qu'elles offrent ensuite à ses
clients pour parfaire la décoration